Dylan thank you so much for being here
today thank you hi Forbes this is
amazing of course I want to start by
talking about your background what were
you doing before you started posting on
social media babe I was in musical
theater all my life I started singing
and dancing when I was three I heard you
had a similar upbringing I do love a
musical theater moment we love music I
saw Wicked last night but I think that
was the one sort of area that I was
allowed to feel feminine and show my
personality off and I I'm so glad that
I've been able to find that throughout
my life that's amazing so tell me about
what inspired your days of girlhood
videos and for everyone who doesn't know
can you please explain what they are and
what they turned into sure days of
girlhood was sort of a a video series
that I started because I was at the
beginning of my transition and I was
looking to all these iconic trans women
but not knowing how to get from point A
to to point B and I thought okay well
why not you know take my followers Along
on this journey and it was originally
supposed to just sort of be like comedy
it was supposed to be light-hearted and
fun and I think over this last year I
found a lot of vulnerability and depth
that I didn't even know was there and
and it's been really beautiful and and
also hard at times but I don't regret
anything and you recently celebrated 365
days I know not terribly recently but
tell me about the big party the event
you had there oh my God best night of my
life tell us so I I knew that I wanted
to go back to my roots which was in
theater and we booked the Rainbow Room
which is an iconic venue in New York and
I wrote the show I found incredible uh
trans talent to put in the show we had
Jonathan vaness and Dominique Jackson
and it was like a birthday in so many
ways but it also was a way for me to
show the world like this is actually who
I am and what I do best talk to me a bit
about your followers who are the people
who are really paying attention to you
watched all your videos and how do you
how are you able to connect with those
fans I think of them as we've got like
the teenage girls their moms and their
grandmothers I I really try to keep my
content accessible to everyone and you
know whether somebody's trans or not I
just hope that they can watch my videos
and feel inspired to unlock a new part
of theirselves and and feel confident
and funny and and finding the funny in
hard situations now I think for for me
and for a lot of people because you are
so um social media forward and you're so
out there a lot of people kind of view
you as the spokesperson for the trans
community did you set out to do that
when you started these videos oh no I
never wanted or intended to be a
spokesperson for the community and I
think I I just ask for Grace as I'm
learning so many things in navigating
this um not only transness but also this
new found success it's happened really
fast and I think that's what's so crazy
about social media is I think it kind of
launches people at a rate that not a lot
of other mainstream media does or can
and I I really am now looking to sort of
not take a backseat I want to stay
really active in my advocacy work but I
want to decide when where and how I'm
going to show up as an activist speaking
of of making those decisions you share
so many intimate details about your life
I mean just recently you shared a
housewarming which looked delightful I
wish you were there it was pretty cute
but what do you decide how like what
you're going to share and is there
anything that's too personal that you
won't share it's funny I I think I
really LED with it all at first because
I noticed that's what people wanted and
now that I have this following and I
have this community this family online
I've realized that people will take
whatever that it is that I feel I'm
ready to share and nobody's forcing me
to say anything so it's it's kind of fun
now to do these check-ins where I've sat
with something for you know a few days
weeks months even and and then finally
tell them when I'm like okay this
happened I'm really excited to tell you
and I've also processed it first that's
amazing um so obviously you came from a
creative background um you're doing
creative work now but as a creative
what's it been like for you to then
shift from that creative mindset into
the the business side of things with
sponsored posts and promotions and
things like that I think I'm becoming a
bit of a
businesswoman as much as I I love the
the creative side I I'm really I love
getting smarter I want to know
everything and I want to know how it all
works I'm really interested not you know
of course being in front of the camera
but I I love the idea of producing and
and I just I think why not learn it at
all how are you teaching yourself or is
someone showing you the ropes I think I
got a lot of great people in my life to
look up to and especially women of
different generations and I think about
these women that have come into my life
whether it's Reese Witherspoon or you
know these these incredible like lever
Cox even talking with her that was
someone who really taught me that I
don't need to put it all out there um
but somebody that I also want to emulate
because I I look at the careers that
they've all built
and I think of what I hope to see in my
future what would you say is the biggest
lesson you learned this year be it
business or in general
ooh I think you have to be careful who
to trust but
also don't become jaded I I always I
want to maintain a sense of uh innocence
and and excitement about life whatever
comes with it now talking about not
being jaded you were you know in the
spotlight earlier this year after there
was some backlash with the sponsored
post has this experience affected who
you partner with going forward
absolutely I now realize that when I
work with a brand that they will forever
be a part of my story and so I want to
make sure we're on the same page going
forward and I want there to be a mutual
respect and not only for me but for my
community what advice would you give to
Brands when they're looking to partner
with a specific Creator I would say talk
to us watch our content See do we want
to put out the same type of things into
the world and I think especially when it
comes to working with trans Talent there
just has to be some communication there
there needs to be uh some advocacy
outside of just inclusive marketing that
makes and speaking of that so one stat
that I love to bring up all the time is
that the lgbtq plus Community has nearly
4 trillion ion do in global purchasing
power we've got purchas we've got the
purchasing power exactly yet brands are
still shying away from lgbtq plus
representation what would you say to
brands that that are despite this fact
thank you we need more of you and we
need you now and what would you say to
the ones that are shying away and don't
want anything to do with the
representation I would say well that's a
disappointment because we're here and
we're not going anywhere and I also
think that there are brands that are
interested in working with someone like
me but maybe don't know how to you know
or nervous to to get involved or ask the
wrong thing and I say let's figure it
out together let's have these hard
conversations because if we don't then
something beautiful can't come from it
and going along with that when these
negative experience happens or there's
anti-trans haate in the country in the
world how do you kind of take back your
own brand and bring authenticity to what
you're posting these these past few
months have been really interesting
because I didn't know brand deals even
existed when I started out online and in
a way I'm grateful because it made me
remember why I started in the first
place which was to make people laugh and
to connect and build an audience and and
perform and I think that that's what I
always want to come back to is is why
did I start this in the first place that
that makes a lot of sense um one of my
my favorite videos of you is last year
you sat down with President Joe
Biden how was that Grandpa Joe no I that
was a crazy experience because I would
have never expected to to do anything
like that I just wanted to be in the
background in a Broadway musical and
then to be sitting there with Joe you
know our president was really amazing
but I think I you know I maybe wasn't
fully ready to do something that major
for the community yet but I now know a
lot of people who are capable of that
and I I'm still proud of it I I mean one
of the things you said that I actually
want to read back to you because it
stood out to me so much is you said to
him Republicans have turned trans and
non-binary people into this thing to
blame society's downfall on and I
thought that was so fascinating and it
was probably the first time a lot of
people around the world were hearing it
it's people want to paint someone like
me to be a monster but it's like hello
you know I I'm I'm just Dylan and I'm a
person that wants love and wants family
and success and friendships and I think
when someone like me or our identities
get politicized there's no real
productivity that can come from that
because we're not being seen as a human
we're being seen as this thing were you
satisfied with the answers President
Biden gave to you or what Republic or
what lawmakers have done in general or
are there other things that they could
and should be doing I left the White
House very hopeful and I think to have
that personal connection with someone
like him was really uh special but I
think right now more than ever we need
action we need advocacy we need allies
and allyship means a lot more than just
you know a text that says I support you
it needs to be out loud and proud and
publicly that makes a lot of sense um a
couple I think it was a couple weeks ago
a couple months ago now you won the
streamy awards two weeks ago it feels
like forever tell me about that
experience and what that how that felt
well I think that that award
specifically was so shocking cuz I I
didn't ever expect social media to be my
way in and especially in such a room
full of so many different kinds of
creators and and being this breakout
award I think um I I just I loved the
energy it made me at a time in my life
where I felt a little bit down or a
little bit self-conscious or nervous of
going forward online I was like hell
yeah I got this let's keep going that's
amazing switching back to the business a
little bit what is the one business rule
that you operate by no matter what oh I
love this um my agent Stephanie she
always says don't react respond and so
if something happens in my life I often
will either at least sleep on it but
sometimes it's taking a few extra days
to really make sure that you know I'm
not coming out of a place of anger or
anxiety or frustration and that it's
it's purely who I am and can operate on
a really neutral level why do you think
that you've gone viral what do you think
gives you the edge over all the other
creators out there I think some humility
I I am never afraid to fall on my sword
if you know I don't do the right thing
or say the right thing I think so much
of social media can be very polished and
and I'm definitely um have fallen into
that sometimes but I love love those
moments online that are so perfectly
imperfect and I never want to be you
know I love being all doed up like this
but I also love to be able to go on the
camera and and show myself with no
makeup and and bed with you know like a
a scrunchie I think that that's what's
beautiful about social media is the the
give and take of it I mean last night
you said it best on Instagram you were
like I was this mysterious Instagram
girl and well that's what I'm telling
you I think for you know as you continue
to grow and find success and you're in
these rooms full of these people that
hold themselves a certain way you start
to adapt but then I realize the reason
I'm invited to that room is because of
who I am and I don't need to change to
become something I'm not that so how do
you how do you think about that and how
do you come up with new material then
that feels like authentic
Rel the audience I think it's it's still
some of the my favorite relationships in
my life for the ones that I had before
the success and in childhood friends in
my family and I think as as I find these
new experiences these amazing
opportunities I always want my followers
to feel a part of it I want them to know
that it's because of them that I'm in
those rooms and that this is a lifelong
relationship that we're going to grow
together say Tik Tok Instagram
everything goes away tomorrow and there
is no more social media this is a purely
hypothetical okay how do you then build
your brand and keep the moment of going
and this business you've built and take
it off the platform and build it into
something more well I think throughout
my life I've always you know tried to
make lemonade with whatever I was given
and I would just keep doing exactly what
I just did which is you know find an
idea find something new that excites me
find the people the collaborators that
really make me feel like the best
version of myself and and run with
whatever the next thing is um and before
social media I was doing standup comedy
so I would figure out how to get back on
stage whether that was Broadway or you
know some comedy club but I think it's
it's the connection this is my favorite
thing because as much as I love you know
talking to my followers and the camera I
love being with other humans that's
amazing what would you say is the
biggest misconception either about you
or and your life or just being a Creator
in general or both
oh oh this is a that's a good question
thank
you I think the common misconception is
that we're these characters or that
we're not real humans that have like
feelings and I read you know read the
comments or a a lot uh can be very heavy
and and I just want to remind people
that we have feelings we're you know we
mess up we we evolve together and
especially people that share so much of
their stories online I think just
finding some respect um would be a good
thing explain to me what the Dylan brand
means what is that the Dylan brand oh
the Dylan brand is is silly um filled
with love but is inclusive for all and
and I I always want to make sure that
anyone who's interacting with me or or
the work that I'm doing feels like they
can be seen in it in some way or another
and and that's what I want to do going
forward with my brand and speaking of
your your future plans I know we talked
about that a bit do you have any type of
of business lines or any new
entrepreneurial things you you're going
to be involved in or want to be involved
in oh hell yeah I I definitely have been
very specific on next steps is what I
want to create but eventually I would
love to do like a production company you
know have my own version of hello
sunshine doing the Ryan Murphy thing I
want to be able to tell stories of of
people that are different than me
especially trans uh humans that I might
not be able to tell tell their story but
I can help Elevate them to tell theirs
that's what I want excellent so tell me
about what's next what's coming up 20124
I can't tell you everything but you I
have to ask I I really want to get back
to my acting rots and I would love to
get back up on stage I think right now
I'm realizing that maybe activism for
transness can look many different ways
and maybe that's me being in a romcom or
you know writing a book and and I think
there's so many ways to continue telling
my story that isn't just online but just
if not more special than what I've
already done now this is just for me
because personally I am very curious do
you have a dream role do you have a
dream show oh my gosh well I would love
to play lwoods in Legally Blonde you
already have the blonde thank you I
think that the trans take could be
really cool on that I would love to do
Glenda or um Little Shop of Horrors
Audrey would be epic I think we got a
long list and we're just going to have
to start checking them off that makes
sense I think you absolutely should
so um this is a bit of a lofty question
so you can take a take a second but what
do you want your legacy to be
oh I think I would like my legacy to be
this sort of idea of like celebrity 2.0
like how can we live in the spotlight
and you know have a large following but
try to do it in a way that feels like
the
kindest most grounded one silly
empathetic vulnerable way possible and I
don't know if that can exist yet I'm I'm
still figuring that out and I think you
know there's certain circumstances where
I might get pushed back on that but I
want to see if we can do it differently
amazing um and one final question for
you for me what would you if you could
go back in time and before you posted
your first video on social media what
advice would you tell yourself buckle up
baby I I would say
you are capable of things that you had
no idea that you could do but you can
and you will do them well and when you
mess up you will admit to your faults
and you will keep on going and I think I
would tell myself to try to enjoy it
more because I I care so much sometimes
that I don't get to really live in the
mo I mean look at this is a this is
amazing so I would say uh just try to
enjoy it more yeah I love that great
advice well thank you so much danan you
love
[Music]
you